[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable the
weekly libertarian News and Views
podcast brought to you by the magazine
of free minds and free markets I'm Matt
Welch joined by Nick Gillespie in a
weird shirt Peter suderman and Catherine
mangyu Ward happy 2023 colleagues
howdy New Year hi Matt happy New Year
all right Nick tell your dumb shirt
story oh yeah so my uh ex-wife bought me
uh a shirt uh on sale at Nordstrom's
it's white and it's kind of like a
baseball shirt Matt I know you like that
and it's got a lazy flower that says I'm
not lazy I just don't like making
profits for capitalists
it speaks to your entire career it's
also laundry day here at Casa Gillespie
so uh you know I figured I'd ring in the
new year with a little double irony
since the shirt is ironic
you know and I'm wearing it before we
give up our uh pregame banter here uh
Catherine were you in bed on New Year's
Eve by 11 o'clock or by 10. I mean I did
make it to midnight did I make it to
midnight in high Style no I did not we
played a rousing game of Ticket to Ride
which I recommend for family game
playing at like 9 00 p.m and that was
that was pretty much the highlight of my
evening
is Ticket to Ride The Beatles game of
heartbreak and public it is a game of
public transit it is a train game
but it's actually it's about competing
train lines my friends it's not about
the trolley problems
oh my God what an amazing that would be
a wood plane you are Mussolini you've
got to get the trains to run on time
otherwise Charlie problem the board game
loses World someone in our listenership
has the wherewithal to make that a thing
do it do it guys I will kick start it
that's a capitalist nicholaspy would
work for
Scott uh Scott ewine Super Fan is
probably already building out of the you
know thousand-year-old uh tree trunk the
uh board you could call it The Little
Engine That Could Kill either one person
or many people we will not be calling it
that all right gang let's have a podcast
today is a uh big day one way or another
for Kevin McCarthy
the Bakersfield Comet does he have a
nickname he needs to have a nickname
yeah
yeah the Bakersfield common is pretty
great he's the natural man he's the last
of the young guys uh he is speaking
uh seeking and speaking uh whatever to
become the new Speaker of the House of
Representatives uh we're going to get to
that a little bit later in the podcast
that drama but first let's talk about
the White House covet policy social
media and the suppression of pandemic
related speech
little timeline for you in July 2021
Surgeon General Vivek Murthy issued an
advisory calling for a quote Whole of
society effort possibly including legal
and Regulatory measures to combat the
quote urgent threat to Public Health
posed by Health misinformation critics
at the time including reasons owned
Jacob sullom pointed out that the very
definition of misinformation was
slippery at best subject to wide
interpretation and threatened to create
a system of censorship by proxy as if On
Cue the very next day again July 2021
President Joseph Robinette Biden II said
about social media companies and I swear
I am not making this up quote they're
killing people look the only pandemic we
have is among the unvaccinated and that
and they're killing people and verbatim
quote
um this job boning as it has become to
be known has worked YouTube that very
summer suspended Senator Rand Paul for a
week for saying that most cloth masks
are ineffective at stopping the spread
of covet which back then was super
outrageous and then a few months later
the CDC basically quietly acknowledged
as fact uh Facebook for months banned
people from uh backing the uh theory
that the uh coveted virus came out of a
Chinese lab
um Spotify yanked a bunch of old Joe
Rogan episodes that had pandemic related
content and now we come to find out
through another one of those Twitter
files installments last week by David
zweig in this case over the Free Press
that various figures including Harvard
epidemiologist Martin kohldorff had
their tweets throttled or suppressed for
saying things that were either informed
opinion or straight up true but just
happened to go counter to the public
health priorities of the administration
and the CDC Catherine here is how
American hero Jacob sullum summarized
the latest bits quote the federal
government has managed to impose
censorship by proxy on social media
platforms acting publicly and behind the
scenes very angry officials have
indirectly limited speech that is
indisputably protected by the First
Amendment end quote so does this job
with your own sense of things Catherine
and if so who's to blame and what is any
kind of possible Remedy or the
beginnings of Remedy uh to like fix this
trend going forward
the government is to blame she said on
the reason podcast boom I mean didn't
yeah God we're really starting off in A
Brave New Direction I just like to keep
people on their toes uh right so as we
said bazillion times over the course of
this unfolding bad uh series of
decisions by various social media
companies these were bad decisions and
uh at the time we I defended them saying
listen Twitter's allowed to make bad
decisions Facebook is allowed to make
bad decisions this wouldn't be the first
this wouldn't be the last and it's
stupid to call this misinformation and
disinformation when uh suppressing it
only makes it stronger which I think the
the Twitter files Fallout has shown
right like we would not still be talking
about any of this except for that we are
digging through the layers of [ __ ] that
accumulated because it turned out that
this was so much worse than we even
thought
and um the the sort of Slow Burn of
Revelations about where the government
intervened uh I think is is super
relevant because uh hopefully everyone
who was embarrassed right I mean the
thing about this you have to remember is
that names are named in all of these
Twitter files so we know each government
official in in some cases uh who
contacted the social media companies
with specific requests suggestions Flags
uh titles as they were called internally
uh which is a plus and
um I each of those people is embarrassed
like this will be a thing that will
follow them I think
um you know that they were they were in
the Twitter files this is sort of like
when people were in the Wikileaks uh
Revelations and that that has followed
them in some ways as well
and you know I hope that at least some
of those people take the lesson this is
not worth it just stop it
um and uh the one that really caught my
eye that I wanted to highlight was
um the Trump administration because
remember this is not just Biden this is
Trump as well asking the tech companies
for help to combat misinformation about
runs on grocery stores
there were runs on grocery store we
remember the runs on grocery stores that
wasn't misinformation now maybe there
were conspiracy theories about it maybe
there were other things that weren't
true but again the very idea of saying
don't tell people a true thing because
they might do things we don't like with
that misinformation with that
information
um it's not misinformation that's like
we're trying to do a noble lie thing and
if you go back to our episodes from when
some of this was originally coming out
we talked a lot about the noble eye and
I think that that's so clearly what this
has turned out to be a collaborative
Noble lie and Noble lies are never all
that Noble in the end Nick
um JD two Chile also wrote about this
fun fact about JD tricilli for you
listeners out there and I know I'm not
supposed to talk about the reason slack
Channel but he's represented sometimes
in the slack Channel by using two emojis
of of red chilies
I think that's really great
um so no I don't even think that that is
true 100 true if you actually paid
attention to slack Nick this is what uh
the kind of thing
um spicy like too chilly Heroes get
those piece about this over the weekend
um that uh maybe one way of thinking
about these companies is not as private
companies but as private-ish
companies what uh to you is uh what is
suggested by that kind of analytical
framework as we try to like figure out
this realm of speech and First Amendment
and censorship or not
yeah I you know first I think it's worth
going back to
kind of the beginning uh perhaps of the
covet era and whatnot but
um and and social media the attacks on
social media of I you know a lot of us
on the libertarian side of the equation
sort of as saying well these are private
companies they can do whatever they want
and and we're not really going to have
that much of an opinion on what they
choose to do as if they were your
favorite restaurant that got rid of your
favorite meal and you'd be like Oh okay
that's their choice I'll just go
somewhere else as opposed to talking or
bitching and moaning and using voice as
well as exit as a strategy for social
change or interaction and I think uh you
know I think that is clearly
insufficient now to talk about the way
that power operates particularly in
terms of speech in terms of media in
terms of public discourse
um and it doesn't mean that Twitter or
Facebook or any other YouTube any of
these companies should be regulated as
public utilities which a bunch of people
at the Free Press Barry Weiss's platform
including herself including people like
Clarence Thomas you know are talking
about a bunch of people on the left
Elizabeth Warren talks about this from
time to time that way Madness lies but I
what I like especially about Jerry uh
JD's uh Mr two Peppers column which I
recommend everybody read along with
Jacob solems is it it really suggests or
makes clear that the kind of dogmatic or
traditional libertarian critique of
power and of um
of um limiting speech was wrong in
focusing simply on government action on
overt government action we live in a
world that was prophecy by people like
Neil Stevenson all of us you know like
his work to different degrees but that
you know we need to be more attuned to
you know what
um and I'm forgetting the name of the
Cato analyst who talked about jaw boning
about government job boning but the
inter penetration of corporate power uh
religious power other kinds of social
institutions and government power that's
where we're at as a society and I you
know I just hope that all of the people
who a couple weeks ago were saying the
Twitter files there's nothing new here
this is [ __ ] I can't believe that
anybody's paying any attention to this
what we are seeing here is a very good
mapping of how power operates now and
this is not you know your grandfather's
censorship it's not your grandfather's
government or corporate power it's
something else that we need to be very
attuned to it uh to Chile also talks
about in his piece a union-backed kind
of Bank organization which is trying to
change Merchant classification codes to
track gun sales and ammunition sales in
a way that kind of gets around certain
kinds of prohibitions or or will lead to
likely outcries for certain types of
prohibitions on constitutionally uh
protected rights that's the type of
thing that we need to be looking at the
way power actually operates as opposed
to anything having to do with a clear
distinction between a private company
and government I mean I also think
though there's a huge danger there Nick
in the way that you just outline that
which is and I know you are alert to
this but like we CA it cannot be that if
Government interferes enough with a
private company then we can do whatever
we want to the private property of that
company absolutely and I think that that
is unfortunately the place that a lot of
people are gonna take this are already
taking this this is this is this sets up
as I don't have to tell you wildly bad
incentives for everyone involved and uh
and it you know it may it may be true
that
um
the sort of pure public private
distinction needs complicating but at
the same time
to say
hey government's bullying this company
therefore
let's break it up governments bullying
this company therefore let's regulate
what it has to carry the government's
bullying this company therefore let's
mandate who they have to do business
with that's bad news like really bad
news I agree and you know it's also
fascinating like what nobody is talking
about is the way uh you know a decade or
20 years ago people were talking about
must carry rules for cable companies and
broadcast TV all of that was the place
where the Public Square was right and
nobody gives a [ __ ] about that anymore
and actually one of the other positive
developments of this past year uh and
Liz Nolan Brown talked a little bit
about this uh you know on uh talking
about her cover story in defensive
algorithms on uh Meet the Press this
past week that's floating around the
internet I highly recommend people check
it out but that you know we kind of
recognize that Facebook Twitter Youtube
do not have monopolies
on you know where conversation takes
place they are not these monolithic
entities that are effectively government
you know uh utilities or something like
that so you know at the same time that
we need to be more attuned to the way
power operates and it operates to try
and limit expression we also need to
recognize that you know what was once
seen as these insuperable
monopolies that needed to be broken up
by the government they don't all they
really need is criticism and empowered
consumers who are like [ __ ] it I'm going
let me uh take those uh analyzes and uh
reform them into a question for Peter
which is to say why wouldn't you uh flow
from this into breaking up a large
company if companies that are very large
and centralized can therefore just be a
tap from which the government gets into
your business
um the business of speech or if it's in
telecommunications the business of
spying on your metadata or if you're in
banking the business of having your
records reported to the bank why not
break it up I can hear our national
conservative friends and our Elizabeth
Warren like Progressive friends saying
this is exactly the reason why you need
to break up large entities because it
makes it more difficult for the
government to exert its will to have a
spasm and make sure that everyone is
Banning Alex Berenson at the same time
I think they're real consumer benefits
to large corporations in many cases and
it also seems to me that a a policy of
breaking up large corporations simply
because they are large and therefore
potentially tools of the government is
one that is ripe for abuse misuse or
just mistakes uh it's not it's just not
necessarily true that every large
company is going to be a sort of useful
vehicle for government mucking around in
people's personal information I think
the better way to go about this is to
place rules on government rather than to
uh place to try to regulate this on the
private side a lot of this reminds me in
many ways of the food pyramid do you
guys remember the food pyramid from the
1980s
terrible graphic that you saw everywhere
in schools but also in journalism in
health journalism in particular in
magazines and in newspapers and that
stuff was just incredibly influenced by
by flawed Notions that were you know
promulgated by the government about what
constitutes a healthy diet and all of
that stuff was deeply wrong and it was
deeply wrong about what you should do to
have a healthy body and in many ways
there are there's overlap with uh with
what has happened with covid except the
difference is it's not just that the
magazine industry was it's not just as
what was happening in the 1980s where
the magazine industry and the health
journalism Health journalists in
newspapers were following what the FDA
and the CDC said uh it's the it's more
like if the entire magazine business was
being publicly threatened by the White
House and also accused of misdeeds like
killing people by perpetuating
information like hey actually maybe you
shouldn't eat too much pasta and sugar
because carbs are bad for you
um right and it's not it's not exactly
obvious what you do about this but one
thing that does come to mind to go back
to what I was saying earlier is that we
in some ways do regulate what people who
are employed by political nonprofits I
guess other nonprofits as well can and
can't say about elections while
maintaining their tax status so if you
work for a 501c3 you effectively cannot
say Vote for This candidate or you can't
say that in your capacity as an employee
of of that organization I'm not saying
that we should uh apply those rules to
the Twitter side of things to the
Facebook side or the social media side
but I think you can maybe imagine
regulating what government officials can
say what they are allowed to communicate
publicly or privately and then make that
actionable in the court somehow or
another and so one but then you have one
thing to reckon with which is
the left-leaning politics of the
staffers of these companies there's just
an obviously an enthusiasm for this sort
of not quite censorship this sort of
workaround censorship that emanates from
the government but is at least
is maybe not always supported but the
the folks at the companies are basically
okay with this in a lot of ways um and I
think that makes this project really
quite difficult because it's it's not
too hard to imagine Twitter making
similar decisions even without direct
government pressure and frankly even if
you set up very strict speech rules for
government officials and enforce them in
the courts which I'm not even sure you
could do that there would be a ways
around that people can figure out how to
communicate and Signal things to each
other in public forums
Catherine I'm going to make the mistake
to ask you to speculate uh live uh I saw
at least one of the people who was
throttled uh by uh Twitter figuratively
throttle whose reach was throttled um by
Twitter I think it was Jay bhattacharya
from Stanford say that uh he feels bad
because uh or you know chagrined
horrified because due to such uh
throttling it affected public policy
like more lives could have been saved
and if it wasn't him that said that I
apologize in advance but somebody who
was one of the original targets who's
been mentioned in the Twitter files uh
said that do you think that the thumbing
on the scale uh which as Robbie Suave
has pointed out in our pages is
overwhelmingly one-sided uh
overwhelmingly in the direction of
basically following what the
government's priorities were uh which
was to get as many people vaccinated as
possible and to have kind of
population-wide strategies
um do you think that that had an impact
on coveted policies themselves and
therefore created damage I think it
probably had an impact on people's
tolerance for particularly Draconian
covid policies that is you know people
in different places arrived at enough is
enough at different times and I I do
wonder if they had been able to see
everything that was being said I guess
um or the things that they wanted to see
when they chose their preferences on
social media rather than what social
media companies wanted them to see if
those moments would have happened
differently
but I will say
Twitter and Facebook and other social
media was an ocean of garbage during
covet was is still an ocean of different
garbage now and so I am a little
hesitant you know I love me some Jay
bhattacharya what a charming and
intelligent dude but like it's a little
I don't know like if if several
thousands more people had seen his
tweets would everything be different
probably not
um and and I do think you know you have
to take that argument both directions
there was there was plenty of genuinely
false stuff that also went down in these
misinformation throttling campaigns
right like there was tons of crazy pants
your vaccine is going to interact with
the 5G to cause your employers brainwash
mechanism to kick in or whatever
um and that's not how the brainwash
mechanism kicks into yes sir yeah yeah
for anyone listening depends on the
reason staff misinformation for me um
but I so I I am very very hesitant to
say had we let this cacophony be a
little more cacophonous the truth would
have won out in this narrow circumstance
or indeed in any circumstance I'm not
that optimistic yeah it probably changed
public policy but frankly which
direction I don't know Nick there's not
just social media though right I mean
John Tierney our friend Catherine's
former boss has written about in uh City
Journal and other places the way the
scientific journals exercised
um very strong kind of peer pressure
about people uh publishing things
Stanford University like a Crackdown on
Jay bhattacharya who works there uh
about this
um uh so like there is a sense in which
that kind of peer pressure escaped the
great cacophony and uh was in the places
where there should have been more actual
expert opinion
um what does it say about like the the
pressures of Conformity and politics
just I maybe I'm uh I'm having a
middle-aged uh menopause again
um but uh like uh you really got to get
on that hormone uh let's get a little
the patch
um but uh I have a hard time believing
that the the same uh level of kind of uh
Conformity would have been applied 15
years ago but maybe I'm looking at this
through uh medical issues on like a
covet issue like that public health you
know that that of like people who've
been doing research in the fields would
uh be kind of frozen out in medical
journals let alone uh I don't know
um I tend to think uh you know and I'm
I'm not gonna go full gnome Chomsky here
but there's uh calculus of consent and
that's been at work in you know in the
modern era saying the post-war era you
know from the get-go and if anything
regardless of and I'm not saying
everything that happened was great and
perfect the way it did but if anything
uh in the social media age we live in a
place where there is much more cacophony
than there was uh you know
up until the internet and the World Wide
Web came out so
um Alex Berenson uh who I Googled very
quickly to see if he was related to
Marissa Berenson which would be far more
interesting than anything he actually
has to say about anything from uh pots
effect on society to uh you know
vaccines causing new you know new horns
to grow out of people's heads and things
like that
um you know he had a he had a good
hearing I think he should have been
allowed to stay on Twitter and on social
media longer despite disagreeing with
them and things like that but the fact
of the matter is I you know this is what
I think the Twitter files ultimately
shows it's showing how power operates
but it's not new because of social media
and if anything I still hold firm to the
idea that we have more freedom of speech
in a wider range of positions
um what the real problem for me is a lot
of the squelching of this stuff is that
it pushes it out of a public forum where
people can debate 8 and discuss and
rather than polarize each other or kind
of get fringy it actually I think having
open really you know strongly argued
debates in full view tends to moderate
and also more importantly find the truth
uh you know however provisional that is
so I don't know
um you know the other thing I'll say is
like when it comes to vaccines and stuff
like that you know one of the things we
keep kind of missing in the way we talk
about misinformation and disinformation
and of course their little brother Mal
information which started to be talked
about towards the end of last year is
that the covid-19 vaccines had the most
rapid uptake of any vaccine that's you
know been known to mankind so you know
it might have had effects on the margins
but I don't know that if anything that
happened on social media changed this or
that in a you know in a significant
direction
I just think there's always been
groupthink and there have always been
Heretics and there's always been uh
power centers that that attempt to
punish Heretics I mean go back to
Galileo right like this is not this is
not something that is brand new in the
social media era or even in you know in
modernity this has been around for as
long as humans have had organized
societies
the last point on this uh which I'll
make and then we'll go to uh our
halftime show of uh of baton twirlers
um I'm app I'm I'm uh I'm struck by the
um coupling
um with the social media is killing us
along with the phrase Pat endemic of thy
unvaccinated
um basically the same day same press
conference it's kind of hard to believe
now uh but that that uh idea the
pandemic of the end vaccinated was like
Central to White House messaging for
about a half a year there until it
became pretty ridiculous because people
kept getting the virus after they were
vaccinated and so um didn't work out
that wet well but it was uh I think a
pretty big tell that they thought that
the problem here is the lack of
vaccination which is a problem I would
uh agree not necessarily with every
single population particularly of
tiny tots and whatnot but that they saw
that problem so big so flashing that
they could organize government to do
anything it could just run the bulldozer
over that until uh you know uh we kind
of uh clear out people who suggest
anything but total vaccination all the
time
um just really led to all kinds of blunt
force until by the end of it and this
includes you know vaccine mandates which
happened at a lot large parts of the
federal governments and local
governments as well
um and uh and I think ultimately we
might see that that rush and much more
on the kind of employer level on forcing
you to do things or in the case of New
York
where Nick and I live
um you know you couldn't go places you
couldn't participate in extracurricular
support Sports if you're a teenager
unless you're vaccinated
um that that may end up sowing a kind of
distrust in vaccines that we haven't
seen even though as Nick rightly pointed
out we had the quicker uptake on this so
when these things are all I think uh
bound tightly together and when a
government has that much power to
exercise its desires when it's looking
at the squirrel and chasing it
um bad things happen all right enough
terrible metaphors I'm thankfully I
can't see Catherine in the Zen Caster
link so I had the the eye rolling is uh
unavailable to my eyeballs we're going
to get to our uh listener question uh uh
email of the week here in a moment but
first a reminder that this episode is
brought to you by better help friends
the month of January is nobody's idea of
a picnic you've got your New Year's
hangover a basket full of holiday season
regrets you're staggering back to work
or school it's still dark and cold and
rainy and bleak
and the self-shame associated with
breaking your New Year's resolutions in
the very first week I'm speaking very
hypothetically here
whatever the cause of your disquiet
chances are very strong you could use a
little impartial outside help in
reorienting your brain towards solving
problems rather than wallowing in them
on the couch that's where better help
the world's largest therapy service
comes in betterhelp has matched three
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists it's an
affordable service 100 online super
flexible if you don't like your first
match swap them out for another until
you find the right fit listeners who act
now can get 10 off their first month
just go to betterhelp.com Roundtable
fill out a brief questionnaire and find
your guide through the looming Darkness
that's better help like prayer
go there today you'll be glad you did
all right reminder send us your succinct
queries to Roundtable at reason.com this
one comes from the delightfully named
Dustin James Harper it's a great pen
name uh Hello friends I just finished uh
listening to the Freakonomics radio
three-part series hold on you're not
allowed to listen to other uh podcasts
okay you can listen to Freakonomics
radio three part series about Adam Smith
the main thesis of the series is that
Adam Smith's views were more nuanced
than we generally think of him most
people tend to cherry pick favorite
ideas from Wealth of Nations while
completely forgetting about his first
work theory of moral sentiments so I'm
curious how have Adam Smith's ideas
shaped your own have any of you read
Adam Smith's works completely and maybe
most importantly do you think Adam Smith
would be a Libertarian small alley says
if he was alive today Catherine have you
had to do uh an Adam Smith weekend for
whatchamacallit
um better than that Matt I went to Adam
Smith camp with Liberty Fund it was a
full week
and we did read maybe not everything but
we got real close we read some deep cuts
from
Adam Smith and uh yeah I think that the
what what is now I think a kind of
emerging conventional wisdom that theory
of moral sentiments Adam Smith is uh in
many ways the better more interesting
deeper Adam Smith than Wealth of Nations
Adam Smith I love that for us uh
absolutely yes I also took a class on
the Scottish Enlightenment as an
undergraduate uh where the seminar
participants ambushed this poor grad
student who did not really understand
that she had gotten every single
libertarian weirdo
like in her in her seminar she actually
was an expert in Adam Ferguson an
underrated Adam uh scholar of militias
among other things
um but she rolled up into this class of
absolute [ __ ] Fanatics and it was
great
um so yes uh all that is Mr good my
personal favorite Adam Smith though is
neither theory of moral sentiments Adam
Smith nor Wealth of Nations Adam Smith
but index Adam Smith
the indices in his books are absolute
works of art I cannot recommend them
strongly enough so for those who have
not partaken like just comically you
know they're sort of like uh if an index
for Adam Smith was written by the onion
like they're just these very comically
detailed and specific entries it's like
you know
fur comma the trade of alpacas in East
Asia or whatever like we don't we don't
know but it's great
um Adam Smith has a lot to teach us man
I don't know if he would be a
Libertarian because
um apparently no one's a Libertarian
anymore but
um and back when I was a child we used
to say that Adam Smith would never have
worn an Adam Smith tie that was a thing
people said
um which I think is like uh actually
surprisingly deep man
um the acolytes of someone are always
worse than that someone in almost every
case and that is true of Adam Smith but
um I wish she was around now because I
bet he'd be fun and interesting and
insightful Nick you're a Scottish
Enlightenment booster or have you come
around to being a detractor now I forgot
but like uh what's your what's your
address yeah I'm uh I'm kind of on the
fence
um uh Adam Smith lived like all of his
life with his mother as long as she was
alive so you know he seems to typify a
uh maybe as a prototype of a Libertarian
in cell type it's his 300th version some
respect man
I don't know if they had basements back
then but you know maybe he was living
there what do you think his life was in
Destiny Smith's podcast would be fire
from his mother's basement sure way back
yeah he would be uh you know she'd be
knocking on the door like do you want
some cookies and crimpets or crumpets
whatever do you think he Preferred
Player versus player
or so what's what I like about Adam
Smith and I uh is
um uh Sandra uh pert and David Levy in a
book uh called how the Dismal science
got its name talk about how classical
liberals and Smith is certainly a
classical liberal
um defied hierarchy whether natural or
cultural
um as you know things that are fixed
orders and um he kind of help Define
people as human who were not necessarily
being considered human in the early
stages of the Enlightenment or the era
of the Enlightenment and I think that's
an incredible uh you know contribution
to to uh human philosophy and thought
and uh for that reason I think you know
he's very very uh worthwhile and and
it's worth going back to the other thing
is he was a classical liberal and he was
not an extremist even though he was a
very devoted foe of mercantilism and
other forms of kind of authoritarian
economic or social or political control
um so I think he would be a Libertarian
but he would be constantly being called
a cockatarian in these days because he's
not uh he's not an extremist uh you know
he believed in Social spending on the
poor he believed in you know Finding
middle grounds on things public
education don't forget everybody's
favorite Even Adam Smith supported
public education people love to get that
one out
I think but you know what part of it is
that he uh and this is a strain of
libertarian thought that I find myself
increasingly drawn to I think people
like Michael Munger uh the uh uh Duke
political scientist slash Economist talk
about this
um he believed that you know a version
of freedom is the ability to participate
fully in society or at least have a shot
which kind of implies certain types of
public spending on people who don't come
from uh you know families or situations
that would allow that hence public uh
education or publicly funded education
and other things I think I think he's a
uh you know he's a proto-libertarian
worth uh looking at think of him he's
like Iggy Pop is to punk Adam Smith is
to libertarian uh uh Peter are you a
Smithy
we've all heard that uh Kane's quote
practical men who believe themselves to
be quite exempt from any intellectual
influence are usually the slaves of some
defunct economist
I am that practical man and Adam Smith
is that defunct Economist I I haven't
read uh a whole lot of Adam Smith
um but I have absorbed a lot of those
ideas in the same way that I I think a
lot of people have right even if you
haven't read Smith you have been
influenced by his ideas you can't avoid
it I think the one that has influenced
me the most is just his sense that that
man is
that man organizes himself and his
Affairs and his economy and his sense of
self via trade right the propensity to
truck barter and exchange one thing for
another and that that is that that that
that that propensity uh sort of extends
between you know in both into the market
realm but also into the social personal
realm right people trade they trade uh
with each other for all sorts of reasons
sometimes for money and for work um but
also for friendship and social reasons
and that these different modes are are
not contradictory in fact they are
incredibly compatible and that that is
what makes a person a person in some
ways that is what makes a whole self is
that sometimes you trade people give you
money and right in exchange for the
thing that you do for them or the thing
that you make but sometimes you trade
because you like them because it's nice
to make someone else a drink
uh my only contribution to Adam Smith
discourse is that I feel like the phrase
the dead hand has has gone kind of away
used to be
um used as often as an invisible hand
whatever uh the dead end is like also a
thing maybe but the invisible the right
red hand
um is what has replaced all of them
um but uh no it's uh it's it was it was
used constantly as a slur
um uh against free market type of
Economics back in the 80s and 90s and is
not anymore I guess people are just like
uh only use trickle down now um the only
people who ever complain or ever talk
about trickle-down economics are its uh
critics uh all right we're gonna move on
because it's 11 41 Eastern as we we
speak and at noon
Eastern the 118th Congress is expected
to be sworn in which means we may see
something we haven't seen in a hundred
years that's back when nicolesby was
only 17 years old uh and that is the
majority Party in the House of
Representatives failing to elect on its
first ballot a new speaker of the house
I said we may see that well it's the
reporting preliminarily indicates that
the main character in The Saga is the
aforementioned Bakersfield meteor and
Comet uh
uh Kevin McCarthy um uh he's facing a
restless and Surly Republican back bench
particularly the cusses at the old house
Freedom caucus which used to be pretty
libertarian uh uh leaning which it is
not at all um Andy Biggs the uh nut
sandwich uh who is now helping run the
thing from Arizona he's been the most
vocal in opposition to McCarthy uh and
uh with a slimmest of possible
majorities that the Republicans have
right now
um it very well may uh last the
afternoon stretching out into days this
leadership uh tussle Peter you live in
Washington you've been following this
with a certain amount of Glee and
interest or least interest uh on uh on
the uh jd2 Chile slack Channel Memorial
uh slack channel uh what interests you
about this and what do you think should
interest uh us small Libertarians well I
think it tells you something about the
state of the Republican Party
particularly in the house
um and uh the the fact is that since um
John Boehner that the house Republican
party has been kind of ungovernable
and Incredibly fractious and we are now
seeing that spill out into a procedural
and Leadership uh vote here that uh it
just tells you they they don't want to
be led by anyone in particular right
it's not obvious for who would who would
be a replacement if Kevin McCarthy can't
lock up this vote and so I think the
most likely outcome here is still that
Kevin McCarthy ends up being the house
leader but he is inherently going to be
a weak leader if the the fact that he
doesn't have the votes as we are
recording this right now that we are
uncertain about whether he will actually
win uh the become you know house Speaker
today uh tells you that there's that he
that he does not have control or command
of this caucus um I guess I would say
from uh from a reasony perspective I
think that a lot of the folks who are
opposing um uh McCarthy
are not
are they're not our best let's say at
the same time
um they're honorary Mexicans uh no
that's not what I would say at the same
time I do I also think that there are
real and good critiques of Republican
leadership in particular uh here and you
go back to the Justin Amash era and he
complained constantly about leadership
in particular about John Boehner's and
you know the way that bills were just
sort of written in private and then
delivered with a with an ultimatum you
either vote Yes or no and we want you to
vote Yes and we're not going to give you
any time to read this and there are I
think real reasons to to be upset about
the way that leadership has conducted
itself and the the centralization of
power in the house uh and and the like I
the negative effects on on on the the
production of legislation in the debate
of legislation because because what you
have now is a system in which everything
runs through the speaker's office and
the the back benchers the the folks who
are you know who who may not have you
know uh top tier committee assignments
they have essentially no ability to
shape legislation except by saying yes
or by saying no and part of what they
are asking for right now and part of the
critics of McCarthy part of what they're
asking for is the ability to weigh in in
Greater detail now again that doesn't
make these folks uh you know uh
favorites uh in any way it doesn't make
these critics uh somehow or another you
know bright legislative minds and it's
not clear that they would use their
power in ways that are particularly
appealing to you listeners of this
podcast
but just because the the people who are
opposed to McCarthy are kind of dim
does not necessarily mean that the
critiques there are all totally wrong
speaking of Catherine's uh X libertarian
boyfriend uh just namash he had a long
uh Twitter uh thread earlier wait is he
an ex-libertarian no he's an
ex-boyfriend libertarian ex-boyfriend uh
sure uh he had a long Twitter thread
um earlier today uh and one of them uh
uh I think the uh the uh the money shot
was uh I'm not a current member of
Congress but I do know what's at stake
I'll gladly serve as Speaker of the
House for one term to show people the
kind of legislative body we can have if
someone at the top actually cares about
involving every representative in the
work of legislating Catherine how does
that uh tweet and that thread uh make
your broken kneecap feel
uh as always
I worry that occasional listeners to
this podcast are gonna get the wrong
impression about my love life but
um
but it is true the speaker of the house
doesn't doesn't matter that's right so
this is this is there's two kind of
silly Seasons that politics enjoys uh on
a sexical basis one is the actually the
speaker does not have to be a member of
the House moment and the other is what
if the Electoral College ties moment we
love those two moments it happens
predictably
we are now in that moment
um you know Amash has been talking about
this for a long time the fact that the
the kind of prog the process has been
broken but on purpose by people who
don't want backbenchers randos whatever
um from the house in particular to
interfere in the serious business of
legislating
um despite the fact that that's their
job now I gotta say as we are watching
some truly dubious characters roll up on
the hill today for the first time uh
including this uh Republican fella who
seems to have made up his entire life
but will be supporting McCarthy we
learned this morning
um there is a
you know I understand how the Pelosi's
of this world got to the theory that
they did to kind of lock out people who
want to make trouble but at the same
time this is the point of the house they
this is the whole idea is that they
should have input on what gets voted on
and if the theory of this lockdown was
that way at least Congress can get its
important work done well no it can't
no it doesn't so it didn't work and we
need to try something else
um I guess we can do uh should we get a
lettuce has someone gotten a lettuce so
that we can track the length of the
McCarthy
speakership if he acquires it like is
there an official lettuce
I don't know if he gets Kayla's room a
long time I think we need like a Boston
Boston bib we need to something poofier
something really watery and weak
um I think it says something that the
most effective uh Republican Speaker of
the House in this century is a convicted
child molester Dennis hastert the coach
who knew how to strong arm not just the
boys that he molested systematically
over years but other legislators when
the Republicans had a very big majority
early in the 21st century Uh Kevin
McCarthy is a man without qualities a
man without a chest he's hated by
everybody in the Republican uh uh you
know delegation I highly recommend
reading Robert Draper's book Weapons of
Mass delusion which is not particularly
out to get Kevin McCarthy but he really
has no principles no core he you know
just his treatment towards Donald Trump
before and after January 6 and around
there he's a he he is uh he exemplifies
what is wrong with politics he's the
anti-justin Amash uh and he will
probably become the speaker and he will
be a failure and he will extend this
period of no decision and of just
useless Rancor that gets us nowhere slow
um you know for however long it's really
remarkable how few Heroes there are here
which is to say none
right I mean even for congress you sort
of hope that maybe there's somebody who
has like enough of a point that you can
rally but no no no no it's this is this
is idiot on idiot action like we have
not seen in Washington for at least two
weeks
um I think there is it's um you know it
also underscores the Republicans have no
legislative agenda uh that's worth
anything you know I'm sure they'll
they'll go deep uh they'll come up with
some acronymic you know Omnibus Bill
that spells out rumor or something like
that but I mean really it's practically
finished yeah you know I mean they
really are I I can remember
you know within the it again this
[ __ ] 21st century is really kind of a
hash but there were times where it's
like you know the Democratic party just
wasn't doing anything in you know when
they were in the minority and that you
know when you have a two-party democracy
and one party has given up you know it's
it doesn't function that well the
Republicans are like that now they're
really
um just terrible I obviously agree with
you because we could use that opposition
gop's lack of uh bigger picture agenda
however some of the folks who are
defending McCarthy or at least saying
look we want to get this vote over with
so we can proceed with governing some of
those folks are pointing to the fact
that Republicans did promise to pass a
bill on day one as soon as they took the
majority in the house to reverse funding
uh reverse the funding boost for the IRS
that happened under Joe Biden and that
probably wouldn't go anywhere because of
the the Senate and probably because of
Biden right
at the same time that's not just it at
the same time that's not a completely
useless thing for them to be doing
that's not okay it doesn't get you
anywhere but it's not a it it's not the
groomer bill that you're talking about
it's not just a culture War nonsense
that's something of actual substance
even if legislation like that is very
unlikely uh essentially impossible uh to
expect to to pass through
um the Bible thank you I would just like
to issue a correction uh Peter allege
that there are no heroes in this story
um I would submit that a former uh house
Republican Jason Chaffetz I think it's
pronounced chafits but has two F's and
I'm just not going to do that from Utah
um has suggested on complications on
Twitter that the um new speaker of the
house be a cocaine bear
um I think that he's on to something and
that is oh that does look like a very
good movie uh the trailers were out this
past week or so uh all right I do agree
that if a cocaine bear were the speaker
of the house then we would have a hero
and it would be the bear do you guys not
remember John Boehner I mean we had it
we had cocaine bear on the hill he was
there was like the sentimental yeah he
was a wine mom yeah he was yeah male
menopause
we won't slander him on our podcast I
guess cocaine Mitch that's true you know
that but that's the upper chain uh so to
speak uh all right let's go to our end
of podcast what kind of cocaine Bears we
have been consuming uh Peter why don't
you lead us off I watched the first
season of The White Lotus it's a show
about how people are kind of sad and
pathetic
thank you
and it's really good
uh Catherine did you have you watched
you're supposed to you're in the group
right aren't you supposed to watch White
Lotus being a lady I am supposed to
watch White Lotus I did not yet
um I watched does anybody watch like
stuff when it comes I watched the
glasses uh when it came out and uh it is
also kind of about how people are
terrible actually
um didn't love the actually all business
people are corrupt charlatans uh thread
which runs not only Through Glass Onion
but also through all of popular media
this year but did love the uh big Agatha
Christie energy that emanated from the
whole thing and
um
yeah I I you know the internet is
already sufficiently enthused I don't
know that I need to pitch it any harder
but uh absolutely delightful I liked
Glass Onion we saw it but I think it has
worn worse in my head since in part
because some of the critiques I've heard
of of it have I I think have yeah have
made me less hypothetic like there's no
knives out right but it couldn't be
because some of the magic of Knives Out
is that you even if you kind of knew
what was happening when you went into it
there's no way you could have known what
that movie was going to be like and this
is very nice outish if this one had come
out first I think it's literally a
sequel to knives out right
if we didn't know if we didn't know
about it the night out vibes and we had
simply consumed this on its own I think
we would have enjoyed the same feeling
of surprise and Deloitte
are we allowed to uh kind of do my I
don't know that this counts as a spoiler
or not but I'll I'll make an alert for
knives out but the final Insight
um you know at uh Ed Norton's character
I think is brilliant and keeps being
demonstrated in an almost hourly basis
by the current proprietor of of Twitter
uh which is that just you know
oftentimes people that we think are
incredibly smart because they make a lot
of money aren't really that smart
especially when they get away from the
thing that they're good at I uh it's
always a good time to remind people to
Google the uh the defamation case
against Henry Ford or that Henry Ford
brought against himself that destroyed
his reputation late in his life because
he was a [ __ ] idiot who was really
good at making cars or automatic
processes but I thought the large
ultimate point of knives out about
billionaires I like that one line I
agree with you there there and I thought
otherwise it's an experience that has
alienated me not just from the rest of
society but apparently the rest of this
podcast I can't believe the uh what
seems to me uh crazy over praise for a
absolutely botched mystery
um that violates all kinds of basic
rules of enjoyable mystery watching
um and uh just you gotta take it take it
on centers I will say
I didn't like it on its own terms
um I was also reading uh this collection
of new Miss Marple Mysteries written by
other authors that just came out
um so it's like so is there like a Sally
Rooney Miss Marvel I mean not literally
but like yes you have immediately
correctly captured the vibe here and uh
so I may have just been in a in an
extremely Agatha Christian frame of mind
I will also have a suggestion those were
better they high five class I needed was
good and you guys are a bunch of haters
and um
who did not enjoy Glass Onion can now
write their own Sherlock Holmes mystery
yay Sherlock Holmes is free from
copyright protection homes is now
um
in the public domain
no no there's actually a couple that are
not in the public domain yet
but there's still a couple of stories
that for whatever reason and um it's
interesting the thing the thing that has
gone into the public domain which is
good is that the sort of later home
stories in which he has feelings
and the homes estate for a long time was
using that the doyle estate was using
that as a excuse to still crack down on
some adaptations if your Sherlock Holmes
had feelings then you were relying on
the stories that were still under
protection but now that is no longer the
case feelings are bad I'm just hoping
something happens where Professor
Challenger is just destroyed and never
you know never comes out into the public
domain uh Nick what did you consume
besides Knives Out badly
I watched uh and it's Glass Onion mat
which you know I would have thought that
just the Beatles title uh would have
enough won you over but I watched the uh
new uh movie Babylon with Margot Roby
and uh
Brad Pitt and uh cast of others uh which
uh is super long so it's like Great
Value it's like the way you know LSD is
a great value drug because it lasts for
hours and it's cheap this is a great
value movie
um it's by the director of La La Land
and it's fascinating in this sense that
it is an attempt to kind of say that big
picture big Studio
Motion Pictures are absolutely essential
to being able to be alive damn it and to
have feelings
um which is just obviously wrong and
it's kind of sad that there's a
fetishization and a glamorization of not
just the studio system as it existed in
the um kind of move from Silent to talky
pictures but just in the public
imagination that's so over but I found
it uh fascinating and really provocative
and entrancing for the three hours and
nine minutes that it took to do it had a
couple of great updates uh or or kind of
plays with people like John Barrymore
and John Gilbert who were silent movie
actors who didn't quite make it fully
Into The Talky urine Clara Beau I highly
recommend it I think if you're a movie
buff there's a lot to be there and then
I saw it with my ex-wife and her husband
and our kids and my girlfriend and I was
wearing the same shirt that I started
this podcast with and we had very
different reactions to it uh including a
bunch of people saying this was about
Hollywood [ __ ] on the very audience
that it needs to sustain itself which is
a plausible and interesting reading I
don't agree with that but it's really
good to look at a mass form which is
still with us and important but has
fundamentally lost its place of Pride I
think as popular entertainment
so I recommend saying Babylon it's also
yet another if I may yet another
instance where Brad Pitt is like
Benjamin Button a character he played he
is aging backwards somehow or whatever
and that should be a spot aspirational
to at least Matt and me and the other
male menopause uh victims who are
somehow listening to this I also saw
Babylon and mostly really enjoyed it
it's a fascinating and technically
proficient film it's also in addition to
being three hours and 10 minutes it's so
much it's so intense the entire time and
at first it's it's overwhelmingly so but
once I locked into its rhythms and sort
of felt got what I think chazelle was
trying to do which is these series of
incredible
um sort of high level set pieces all of
which ends kind of almost all of which
end with effectively
uh a punch line
um and he just strings these things
together and it's very episodic it's
almost like a sort of mid-century novel
in that way of this these sort of there
is a through line here but it's also
like you're supposed to watch it for
each 15 or 20 minute bit as much as you
are for the whole thing and once you see
that that's what he's doing and you can
just appreciate these absolutely
marvelously staged set pieces uh I I
think it becomes a much more enjoyable
film
uh my
um consumption was a couple weeks ago uh
Jerry Lee Lewis the killer uh died
um great rock and roll Pioneer allows a
human being uh and as I do in those
circumstances particularly when
um the artist is someone who you know
everybody knows who he is but you don't
actually go out and seek him out
um I asked my local robot to shuffle
songs by and uh I was blown backwards by
the initial Choice which was a uh early
70s recording
um during uh Jerry Lee's uh country
phase of Cold Cold Heart by Hank
Williams great song
um uh he had done you know his usual
rockabilly 50s versions of that back in
the day uh but uh his country music
character and Persona in the early 70s
is fantastic I had uh heard a friend
talk about growing up listening uh to
like just knowing Jerry Lee Lewis as a
country artist and not as a rock and
roll Pioneer because his parents had
listened to these country records I
never really quite understood that just
was that uh Kevin McCarthy is the beggar
still comment no he can't even listen to
country music right being from
Bakersfield which is uh hard to do
um but uh no it is true terrific uh his
I mean Hank Williams is a one of a kind
singer and you shouldn't be able to
um sing in a way that is competitive
with him and yet uh Jerry Lee Lewis does
while also playing piano uh kind of rock
and roll piano better than just about
any jazz pianist or or Blues pianist you
can name it is just a brevora
performance and that can immediately
take you down the rabbit hole I can't
necessarily recommend a specific one of
his country records and online and on
Spotify or whatever there's a lot of
collections just go and like toggle in
between them
um and do it to your heart's content he
had really good musicians back then
those records are really really good and
you can just see the full force of the
man's Artistry he just was uh an
astonishingly
um vibrant and great musician and again
a really horrible human being and who
cares for all of that Matt may I ask you
is you know as we uh think about the
killer uh Jerry Lee Lewis is there
anything an artist could do where you
would be like I'm not listening to their
work anymore I'm not consuming their
work I don't think so I mean if uh it's
I mean I if if there's a Charles Manson
version of never learn not to love in
addition to the Beach Boys version of it
I'm going to listen to it I'm not gonna
like it probably because it wasn't very
good but uh and the song is not very
good but uh no I mean I I think you've
listened to uh everyone has their own uh
uh algorithms for this stuff but there's
a lot of horrible people out there a lot
of murderers I listen to Phil Spector
um you know uh Tunes uh wrote or
produced
um and uh yeah he murdered some people
you couldn't really listen to Derek and
the dominoes could you if you if you
suddenly had like a a high moral
threshold uh another or let alone The
Mamas and the Papas I mean it's there's
a lot of just grisly human beings out
there uh I think Mama Cass you know
acquitted
you know yeah that one Daddy Daddy was
getting a little handsome yeah
Bears who have done cocaine like I'm
about to do yeah uh Catherine you're in
the booth of them right so you can just
gut him in person yeah you know I think
if we decriminalized cocaine the whole
premise of cocaine bear which I saw the
trailer for while watching Babylon you
know if there was a legal regulated
cocaine Market that bear probably
wouldn't have been taking cocaine in
such large quantities I had a whole wrap
prepared about how my New Year's
resolution had to do with Adam Smith and
I gotta say you guys are making it hard
for me to keep it right now
what is it going to be I was going to be
more empathetic is going to like bring
the it's gonna bring the impartial
spectator into my life I was gonna
understand where other people are coming
from and already I'm just like oh my
gosh and you were gonna do that you were
gonna do that as a rep
yes
empathy like uh retail Is for Suckers he
called it sympathy so we can prevent
pretend like it's a different deal and
certainly not have to talk about empaths
which are not a thing all right let's
accept in Star Trek the Next Generation
okay I think we're I think we're in Team
America the best we could possibly
manage at this point uh let's stop thank
you for listening everyone
um tune in next week for more Tales of
Catherine regretting her life
um listen to all of our podcast
recent.com podcasts Nick you got an
event coming up this week is it too late
to to get in on it or what's going on no
uh tomorrow in New York City at the blue
building at 222 East 46th Street between
second and third Avenue just down the
block from the infamous Sparks
Steakhouse
uh in Midtown a fantastic reason
Speakeasy a live taping of the recent
interview podcast with Andrew tatarsky
and Maya solovitz talking about harm
reduction approaches to drug policy to
addiction treatment and a host of
related Concepts that would make the uh
world a better place uh go to reason.com
events and you will get information
tickets are ten dollars doors open at
six there's beer wine soda food and a
hell of a lot of conversation reason.com
and if you like what recent Foundation
does which publishes this podcast and
everything else besides and does public
policy work go to reason.com donate
um think about providing a little tax
deductible donation here in the year
2023 all right we'll see you next week
thank you goodbye good cocaine there
[Music]